bonjour et bienvenue au parlement
européen pour cette nouvelle session
d'europe hebdo nous sommes aujourd'hui
ici en plateau pour une émission
spéciale la présidentielle française vue
par les eurodéputés étrangers et nous
sommes plutôt bien entouré catllar oui
avec nous quatre invités quatre regards
croisés sur la campagne véronique de
kaiser députée européenne devenue de
belgique du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates
bonjour à vos côtés rodi kratsa vous
êtes vice présidente du parlement
européen
certains moments et vous êtes du groupe
ppe le groupe majoritaire ici au
parlement européen où venait de grèce en
face de vous andreas schwab député
européen du même groupe conservateur et
allemands et puis miguel portas ce le
leader du front de gauche il se veut
dire portugais du bloc de gauche
portugais merci avocate d'être avec nous
alors peu après les événements de
toulouse la campagne française reprend
peu à peu son cours
quelle est la place de l'europe dans
cette campagne on fait un petit tour
d'horizon des programmes avec aurélie la
face
les parties sont nombreux à réclamer une
refonte des institutions européennes le
modem entend redonner de la légitimité à
l'europe pour cela deux mesures
principales l'élection suprême universel
d'un président de l'union et l'élection
du parlement sur la base de nouvelles
circonscriptions paneuropéenne à
l'extrême gauche jean luc mélenchon
souhaite une renégociation du traité de
lisbonne et une réforme des trois
principales institutions européennes
parlement conseil et commission pour le
npa il faut une europe des peuples pour
lutte ouvrière des états unis
socialistes d'europe à droite marine le
pen nicolas dupont aignan et jacques
cheminade défend des positions
souverainistes et réclame une sortie de
l'euro
si le candidat de debout la république
souhaite une europe à la carte
la présidente du front national veut
rétablir la primauté du droit français
à l'ump on joue également la carte des
eurosceptiques
nicolas sarkozy il s'est prononcé pour
un renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières de l'union
mise en place d'un bail européen acte de
voler à cette mesure
favoriser les entreprises européennes
dans les contrats publics et aider les
sociétés qui produisent en europe
à gauche c'est le pacte de stabilité
portée par nicolas sarkozy et angela
merkel qui fait l'unanimité contre lui
françois hollande veut le renégocier et
y ajouter un volet croissance
jean luc mélenchon demande sa suspension
pure et simple
enfin europe écologie et le parti
socialiste propose la création
d'eurobonds émis par la banque centrale
européenne
voilà deux thématiques européennes
majeures la réforme de schengen est
celle du pacte budgétaires alors
françois hollande propose de renégocier
le traité de discipline budgétaire
actuellement en cours de ratification en
lui ajoutant un volet sur la croissance
verdict de kaiser est ce que vous
soutenez cette proposition bien sûr on
soutient cette proposition mais cette
proposition ne fait que reprendre ce que
en tout cas au niveau du parlement
européen les socialistes demandent
depuis
des mois et n'ont pas réussi à voir
d'ailleurs et dès qu'on a commencé à
négocier cette fameuse législation qu'on
appelle le six pack nous nous sommes
plaints de cette absence de dimension
sociale et de dimensions de relance de
l'emploi et de la croissance mais une
croissance qui amène de l'emploi pas
n'importe quelle croissance et c'est
like a peut-être beaucoup à discuter
andré âge là que vous êtes justement
allemand conservateur est ce que vous
seriez prêt à renégocier ce traité alors
moi je ne pense pas qu'on va renégocier
le contrat ça s'est jamais fait en
europe
en europe il faut que les gouvernements
en place négocié et conclu des contrats
mais ça veut pas exclure qu'on peut
toujours et partout améliorer ce qu'on a
décidé il faut savoir qu'il faut de
l'argent pour financer ces emplois et
cet argent ne peut pas être empruntés en
plus de mon point de vue alors ce traité
rodi kratsa pour répondre à pour
compléter ce que dit votre votre
collègue dit qu'on peut pas tourner
aussi en europe mais en même temps ce
traité tel qu'il est rédigé actuellement
est fondé sur une règle d'airain le
respect de la discipline budgétaire avec
l'austérité est ce que l'austérité peut
être un projet politique envers en grèce
pas du tout jeter ne peut jamais être un
projet politique
elle ne peut pas donner de réponse à
l'europe à la situation actuelle liés à
la gouvernance internationale non plus
on a besoin de la croissance surtout en
europe la croissance a besoin comme
condition la l'assainissement budgétaire
on a avec qui longtemps avec de l'argent
empruntait ça il faut quand même prendre
en considération est en pleine
conscience à mener une autre politique
ne savait pas dit que l'austérité
l'exemple grec nouveau les manières sud
rue manière voyante que l'austérité ne
jamais peut apporter de la croissance
qu'il faut négocier ce qu'il sera il
faut il faut une composition de la
rigueur en grèce nous avons besoin de la
rigueur rationalisation de nos dépenses
de notre gouvernance est de mesures de
croissance
audacieux est sincère donc les forêts
gagnent aussi sous traiter de vous
orienter en genevois moi je ne vois pas
de négocier un traité qui est en cours
de ratification dans le parlement
il faut être assez réelle sincère mais
je suis il a beaucoup il ya beaucoup des
deux des solutions de croissance que
nous pouvons apporter à l'europe que
nous avons pas épuisé c'est pas la
rainbow ciation de traiter c'est de
mettre en valeur tous les moyens que
nous avons eues rebonds et en français
on a dit aux obligations ars obligations
le modèle pareillement fait des
propositions très mûr très juste sur la
question et aussi des obligations de
grands projets à l'envi des portes à
l'europe a beaucoup de moyens à arriver
à la creuse qu'on se dit l'exemple
portugais qui est notre pays qui porte
et ça c'est le problème de la
proposition d'hollande
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de croissance avec
austérité
ou une ou l'autre les deux en même temps
une sorte de mix c'est une sorte de nos
politiques
véronique oui il ya tout de même quelque
chose qu'il faut clarifier parce que on
dit ici traitée pour les les gens qui
nous écoutent comme s'il s'agissait d'un
même très tic le traité de lisbonne
c'est un pacte qui était fait avec 26
gouvernement en place qui représente une
certaine tant dans la france et
l'allemagne qui ont été rapidement la
france et l'allemagne mais c'est un
pacte entre gouvernement qui devra
d'ailleurs être soumis à référendum en
irlande et en politique ce qui a été
fait à un moment donné peut toujours
être défait ce n'est pas quelque chose
dans lesquels démocratiquement le
parlement a eu à voir ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est communautaire
c'est une entente entre copains voilà et
les copains d'aujourd'hui ne seront
peut-être pas les copains demain alors
justement les copains de demandes sont
peut-être pas des copains d'aujourd'hui
nicolas sarkozy a proposé de réformer
également l'espace schengen
rapidement qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé ce que c'est une vision
électoraliste qu'est ce qu'il a cherché
à faire
si j'étais encore écouter les belges eux
ils sont quasi consanguins avec les
français alors suis comme ça là la
campagne française n'en rate pas un mot
je dois dire que le choc de la
renégociation de schengen qui était en
effet d'annoncer finalement on l'a
ressenti vraiment comme une provocation
dans un climat contre l'immigration et
aidera ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
schengen est en train d'être réformé
depuis un an qui est des réunions sur
ces réformes trois jours avant cette
sortie de sarkozy auquel monsieur
guillon n'a même pas assisté alors si la
réforme de schengen est tellement
importante
pourquoi ne pas dire qu'elle existe et
que la france a fait la politique de la
chaise vide d'autant que madame kratsa
vous étiez en filigrane un petit peu un
petit peu dans le viseur de nicolas
sarkozy la grèce étant la passoire entre
guillemets de l'union européenne avec sa
frontière avec la frontière gréco turque
comment vous l'avez ressenti et vous
savez nous on aura le problème est sonné
pour l'espace schengen c'est une
conquête de l'europe à voir la mobilité
libre en europe en mai
le système de visa commun c'est très
important je pense
symboliquement essentiellement menoua le
problème de notre offre en frontière
avec la turquie et c'est là où la
frontex agit c'est assez particulier
c'est pas la circulation dont les roms
mais si on veut avoir un espace schengen
il faut le prévoir des réformes elle
adaptée aux nécessités
alors revenons si vous le voulez à la
campagne présidentielle une campagne
dont on parle beaucoup également dans
les parlements de l'union européenne je
vous propose d'écouter ces quelques
réactions recueillies par julien sola et
sandra cerqueira clé
les britanniques sont très intéressés
par les élections françaises qui ne
l'est pas toute l'europe s'intéresse à
ces élections build your up
moi j'ai bienvenue au contraire des
beaucoup de mes collègues contacter la
mère qu'elle a annoncé qu'elle va
soutenir sarkozy nicolas sarkozy parce
que c'est normal ils appartiennent
à la même famille politique et la
politique française et la politique
allemande
c'est pas la politique nationale c'est
toujours aussi la politique européenne
ce qui se passe en france un impact
direct aux citoyens allemande à partir
de l'élection du président du
gouvernement
nous ne serons très très intéressés
voire le proposition qui la france fera
au futur pour voir leurs répercussions
au cul peut avoir à l'espagne et à toute
l'union européenne au long de cet ami et
donc je crois il n'est pas difficile à
comprendre que je souhaite le succès de
mon ami mais sur le niveau international
dont le monde diplomatique dont les
relations institutionnelles
le président du parlement européen
travaille avec celui ou celle qui est
élu par le peuple français
alors question avoue andrée h soit pour
répondre à votre collègue martin schulz
collègue socialiste il ya quelques
semaines l'hebdomadaire allemand der
spiegel évoqué l'existence d'un front
anti hollande de la part des dirigeants
conservateurs de certains dirigeants
conservateurs européens pour ne pas
recevoir le candidat socialiste est ce
que françois hollande est aujourd'hui
persona non grata en allemagne je ne
pense pas du tout je ne pense pas du
tout et on a bien vu que les socialistes
ont fêté leur campagne avec les
socialistes allemands mais je pense que
le chef du gouvernement en europe en ce
moment en vraiment d'autres soucis que
de faire des entrevues en entretiens
avec des candidats il ya tellement a
décidé qu'on peut pas parler
historiquement pardon je vous coupe
monsieur femme est historiquement et
angela merkel avaient reçu ségolène
royal en 2007 les candidats français à
la présidentielle ont toujours été reçus
qu'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
françois hollande n'est pas reçu par la
chancelière
alors moi je n'ai pas décidé à la
chancellière donc je ne peux pas vous
dire sur quelles bases cette décision
s'est prise
sissel ses prix mais ce que je dirais
c'est que danser dans ce contexte actuel
on a tellement des enjeux a décidé qu'on
n'a pas vraiment envie maintenant de
mener des campagnes nationales au niveau
européen et je pensais c'est un peu ça
le bec aux hommes tout ça nickel potasse
est ce que vous croyez en l'existence
d'un front anti hollande en europe
point de vue j'ai vu qu'il y a quelques
problèmes d'agenda mais vraiment mon
problème c'est un autre ce que madame
merkel a des problèmes en allemagne
toute l'europe est à sa cause alors ils
veulent elles veulent donner une petite
sarkozy c'est une sorte participation
indirecte c'est pas possible ce débat
qui va laisser partir madame kratsa qui
doit retourner dans l'hémicycle mais
aussi d'avoir été avec nous à la presse
européenne
toute la presse européenne semble
s'intéresser beaucoup à cette campagne
entre spectacle et roman feuilleton
reportage dans les coulisses des
meetings politiques français avec paul
bouffard ses campagnes je vois qu'il est
très compétitif mais en même temps très
idéologique parle pas beaucoup de tous
les problèmes qui peut y avoir au plan
international chaque jour il ya des
petites phrases qui sort de gauche de
droite
cette campagne aurait été beaucoup plus
axé sur l'économique 2007
chaque jour dans les meetings et des qg
de campagne
on croise de nombreux journalistes de la
presse étrangère david picanto et
correspondant de la tb pour la chaîne
publique espagnole
il suit la telenovela présidentielle en
france jean philippe scholler et le
journaliste accrédité par la télévision
suisse romande
même si elle n'est pas dans l'union la
suisse se passionne pour notre théâtre
politique
rudolf ballmer travail pour le taz le
quotidien berlinois die tageszeitung
proche de la gauche allemande
aujourd'hui le reporter allemand veut se
rendre compte des enjeux de campagne
notamment de la situation du bassin
industriel normand en ruines
rencontre avec les syndicalistes de
petroplus la raffinerie est menacée de
fermeture
elle est devenue le symbole de la
désindustrialisation française et ses
ouvriers compte beaucoup sur la présence
des journalistes étrangers
tout ce qu'il peut étendre le la
compréhension aux autres pays ce sera
c'est que du bonus pour tous
interview en boîte direction le parc des
expositions de rouen ce soir le candidat
du front de gauche tient meeting rudolf
ballmer doit approcher le phénomène
mélenchon selon lui il apporte un plus
dans la campagne après et espace pour la
presse
le journaliste n'est pas là par hasard
l'axé franco allemand est une clé de
voûte de la construction européenne
jusque dans certains partis politiques
la ligne ce portail qui est le parti de
gauche qui était un peu le modèle pour
jean luc mélenchon dans la création de
son propre parti pour idole ballmer
l'homme politique français est presque
une rock star
les meetings des shows il est venu
tester le charisme du candidat mélenchon
c'est l'entrée à l'américaine d'ailleurs
ça a fait un peu rire non quand on
connaît le lieu où année avec le parti
de la noce
à la question le jeu politique français
et allemand se ressemblent utile il
répond c'est tout de suite à un combat à
trois mines m
en attaque même les conjointes c'est
impensable des choses comme ça dans un
pays comme l'allemagne
on a l'impression tout est très fils
très feutrée depuis maintenant quatre
ans la vie de picasso scrute la
politique française
pour le correspondant de la première
chaîne espagnole impossible de passer à
côté de cette campagne
ça c'est mes meubles d'affaires mais
deux
comme les chanteurs
c'est
même l'espagne
les voisins
c'est un ami très cher
depuis la crise de 2008 plusieurs
gouvernements européens ont connu
l'alternance et la survie du président
sarkozy à la tête de la france intéresse
les espagnols marquent un point
d'inflexion dans sa campagne en nitrates
à une belle récupérateur un contrat
le look akiyama la marque en espagne on
aime l'exception du jeu politique
français
car selon eux une campagne chez les
voisins du nord ces 24 heures sur 24
mais vous savez des programmes avec plus
de trois heures pour le candidat nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande ça ce sont des
choses quitte qui sont surprenants pour
my home parce que chez nous on n'a pas
l'habitude dans ces cas là
à la télévision suisse jean philippe
scholler connaît bien les rouages de la
présidentielle chaque semaine sa
rédaction lui commande plusieurs
reportages les téléspectateurs suisses
livrent ce rendez vous politique comme
un véritable feuilleton madame bonjour
madame pour la télé suisse
qu'est ce qui va faire qu'aujourd'hui
les choses vont changer pour lui parce
qu'il n'est pas très haut dans les
sondages en ce moment programmé qui est
ce qu'il faudrait pas que les candidats
parlent plus des vrais problèmes comme
la dette par exemple où le pouvoir
d'achat des français ce que ça c'est pas
quand même quelque chose qui est le plus
important finalement pour le journaliste
helvétique
la campagne a du mal à trouver son
rythme sur le fond que vraiment ce que
les gens attendent à savoir comment
résoudre la crise
on est des problèmes de logement comme
on augmente le pouvoir d'achat on n'a
pas grand chose au final les entre
d'intérêt ne sont pas les mêmes d'un
côté ou de l'autre des alpes et la
manière de faire de la politique non
plus c'est vrai que la vie politique
française à dix ont ce petit côté
sulfureux entre guillemets polémique
qu'on n'a pas tellement en suisse des
politiques assez calme nous en suisse à
y regarder de plus près pour un
journaliste étranger la présidentielle
française est the place to be
comme aux états unis ou encore en russie
cette couverture médiatique est une des
plus importantes au monde pour les
rédactions étrangères alors en france on
dit cette campagne qu'elle est
particulièrement violente
andré à ce jour quel est votre sentiment
quand vous regardez un peu ce qui se
passe chez vos voisins français comment
est ce que vous percevez cette campagne
présidentielle je trouve elle est
fascinante car en france 24 sur 24 on
regarde que quelques candidats et je
trouve c'est fascinant d'un pays comme
de but de l'allemagne s'est facilement
mais je trouve cette c'est différent en
allemagne c'est absolument différent
mais il faut ference
il faut faire attention je trouve que
dans cette campagne et les français
n'oublient pas que c'est pas seulement
la france qui est la concernée que c'est
aussi un peu l'europe et je trouve
personnellement que nicolas sarkozy a
jusque maintenant toujours joué cette
carte européenne de manière sérieuse
bien que dans une campagne électorale il
ya toujours des enjeux qui sont un peu
plus difficiles à communiquer et ça que
je trouve c'est très positif
véronique de keyser est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment d'une droitisation de la
campagne la presse européenne a des mots
très durs la presse même
outre-atlantique évoqué nicolas
le pen est ce que vous avez ce sentiment
là est ce que pour vous c'est marine le
pen qui impose ses thématiques dans la
campagne ou pas j'ai en tout cas le
sentiment d'une campagne à ces salles de
ce côté là et très complaisante
vis-à-vis des thèses de l'extrême droite
et je dirais que c'est pas seulement la
presse européenne qui lui a eu un débat
au parlement européen où verhofstadt qui
n'est pas socialiste a créé dans la
salle même nicolas sarkozy et le
candidat de l'extrême droite ou bien
c'est marine le pen dans cette tournure
la inquiète ici au parc inquiète
terriblement au parlement européen et on
a vraiment l'impression qu'il ya eu à un
moment donné un glissement c'est en
dessous de la ceinture et que c'est
quelqu'un qui devient quelqu'un aux
abois et qui est prêt à n'importe quoi
alors c'est de la spéculation mais en
tout cas ça ne correspond pas à l'image
que l'on se fait d'une droite française
qui n'a jamais été enfin qu'il n'est
plus l'affairé dreyfus peut-être mais
qui n'a jamais été à ce niveau-là de
racisme d'intolérance et cédera c'est
votre site au visage de l'extrême droite
je trouve qu'on qu'il ya des points sur
lesquels on peut s'interroger mais quand
même il faut juger le gouvernement et
nicolas sarkozy sur les actes qu'il a
fait et je trouve qu'on peut bien
fortement dit que les actes que le
gouvernement sous sarkozy a fait céder
act européen et dans une campagne
électorale je voudrais vous signaler
aussi il est important et c'est une
expérience que nous avons fait en
allemagne
il faut éviter un parti à droite du cdu
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire
attention avec sériosité de réunir les
gens derrière des positions finalement
de mon point de vue européenne et pour
l'instant je n'ai pas vraiment de doute
que nicolas sarkozy va continuer cette
fois c'est aurait évité si pour éviter
un parquet à la droite de la droite
on est obligé de reprendre les thèses de
ces partis avec ce type de langage là
c'est inacceptable c'est ce que je n'ai
pas dire
ironique ce ce que je dis c'est qu'il
faut juger les politiques sur base des
actes et les actes le gouvernement
sarkozy a fait c'est exact européenne
oui mais sur le par exemple on a eu le
débat sur l'identité nationale en france
il ya une polémique sur le halal il ya
une immigration qui est de plus en plus
contrôler et limiter l'immigration
familiale le regroupement familial
l'immigration de travail est-ce que ça
c'est des thématiques il emprunte à la
droit d'exister en prénationale l'égard
des roms
aussi à un moment donné c'est ça les a
déjà alerté presse qu'il s'était un
fonds européen cela est ce que je trouve
on peut s'interroger sur sur quelques
points c'est ce que je nous ai dit début
mai en principe en principe je trouve
qu'il faut d'un point de vue européen
juger un gouvernement et un président
sur les actes et là je reste assez clair
je trouve qu'on peut vraiment dire leur
colère
il a aussi raison quand il dit qu'on
doit juger sur les actes et ce qui est
vrai et c'est que sarkozy et le demi
chef d'une europe dirigée par madame
merkel et qui donne pas des bonnes
nouvelles aux peuples il y à au moins 3
ou 4 à aucune bonne nouvelle
toujours des mauvaises mesures la
différence celle du crédit elles sont
très mauvaises
ou simplement mauvaise ça c'est le
problème mais je pense qu'en tout cas il
ya un vrai changement dans cette
campagne électorale française
je pense et je pense que le facteur 9
c'est effectivement la nature déjà luc
mélenchon à la gauche alors justement
comment vous regardez ses chaussettes
non c'est une nouveauté exactement parce
que tous les études d'opinion ne donne
pas les aides qu'il ya une droitisation
de la france au contraire sur le second
tour c'est clair qu'il ya une majorité
de gauche
comment nous interpréter l'aja l'a vu
faire une leçon de gauche en france je
pense que cette montée el adoua
un mélange intéressant difficile de
pratiquer par exemple pour tous voilà
mon pays qui est un mélange entre un
discours qui est axé sur les
propositions concrètes sur la vie des
gens et aussi avec une idée de
révolution citoyenne d'insurrection
civique dira d'ailleurs que la capacité
de réalisation des fondations nationales
et en même temps la fondation
démocratique et sociale du rop que je
pense que ça fait une combinaison qui
permet à jean luc mélenchon faire une
sorte campagne tous azimuts hilton du
combat à l'extrême droite avec clarté
il discute avec hollande mais d'une
façon qui n'est pas sectaire il dit il
parle au peuple de gauche mais il parle
à tous les écocentres l'insurrection et
qui me promet de prendre la bastille
skis a pas quelque chose d'excessif non
pas excessif il ya risque majeur il a
évidemment un jeu avec l'histoire et
l'histoire de la france qui a une
dimension symbolique mais ce qu'il dit
c'est l'inscription la surrection
civique c'est d'un jour où on va mettre
les votes
nous allons ouvrir la porte à la 6ème
république en france et à une ré
fondation en europe avec une sorte de
victoire pour le tour de l'europe contre
la droite andré assurée ce que ça vous
inquiète cette candidature par exemple
de jean luc mélenchon et les
candidatures ne m'inquiète pas du tout
haut mais ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
c'est quand même une façon de parler de
l'europe que je n'aime pas du tout
c'était la même chose avec montebourg
quand il a dénoncé l' affaire avec
bismarck
je trouve qu'on trouvait tout ce que
nous faisons tout ce que nous faisons il
faut le faire ensemble
peut-être on parle pas assez de cela
qu'on est interdépendant entre les
belges entre les allemands entre les
français entre les portugais mais aussi
sur des réformes structurelles et si on
parle de l'austérité l'a toujours écouté
qui peut re payer cette dette que les
gouvernements ont fait dans le passé
personne avant les européens qui peinent
avec des dunks à la grèce une la banque
centrale européenne qui a de la
liquidité est jusqu'à l'infini pour tous
les mêmes privés mais il n'ya pas pour
les peuples et pour les états
la dette doit bien se payer un goûter
tous leurs jeux pour les vols à la grèce
rien pour les citoyens véronique de
kaiser juniors vous pouvez oui merci lee
a certainement phénomène
mélenchon qui est un mélange de tribun
de leader un peu charismatique qui joue
du symbole j'en prend la bastille et
cédera moi ça ne m'inquiète pas ça ne me
quitte pas et je pourrais dire que
j'étais la veille la veille de la
reprise très bas si j'étais avec des
syndicalistes en belgique me disait
écouter on peut pas rester tard parce
que demain on va reprendre la bastille
avec mélenchon et cette année ce sont
donc élus des cartes le belge oui mais
l'écart de belges sont partis reprendre
la bastille vous savez je jure d'être
très proche de la france
mais bon mélenchon reprend athènes
importance qui est celui de la
renégociation du traité de lisbonne pour
rester et c'est le non français au
traité ne laisse pas des réductions les
nazis maintenant alors dit qu'ils en
profitent aussi qu'il aimait il au
profil a d'ailleurs il utilise ce nom
alors qu'on sait bien que malgré ce que
la gauche avait dit l extrême gauche
avec et à ce moment là c'est à dire si
c'est le traité de lisbonne s'est coulée
dans le bronze et s'est fait à jamais et
ses draps on sait bien qu'entre et
essuie un autre et qu'il y aura un jour
un autre traité après le traité de
lisbonne
mais mélenchon capte tout ça dans un
cadre aussi une dimension de captation
de l'électorat qui est déçu par hollande
celui par exemple de montebourg parce
que hollande fait une campagne un petit
peu plus au centre
vous qui lisez comment est ce que vous
avez certainement des orientations il ya
certainement une captation d'une partie
de l'électorat de verre qui plafonne
extrêmement bas et je sais pas à ces
spécialistes pour le faire je dirais que
mélenchon
bon je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils captent
les one hollande vous pourrez discuter
parce qu'il savait mieux que moi mais
c'est le front du refus
et c'est aussi ce mouvement des indignés
qui se lèvent absolument partout en
europe qu'il a su capter toutes plus
légèrement pour revenir sur la forme de
cette campagne
andré à cheval vous qui êtes allemand
est ce que ça vous surprend cette
manière de faire de la politique de
promettre qu'on va prendre la bastille
de faire des grands meetings avec une
dimension de show à l'américaine est ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer ça chez vous en
allemagne alors moi ça me surprend pas
du tout mais c'est vrai dans un système
électro dans le système électoral
allemand ça serait pas vraiment pensable
mais je ne dira pas que c'est bien ou
mauvais c'est comme ça et et c'est
intéressant de suivre ça de loin
en fait oui et ça ça démontre tous les
sentiments tous les émotions qui
existent en france en ce moment et c'est
intéressant de suivre ce modèle portable
avec des patients et des émotions c'est
bien ça j'aime bien merci à vous quatre
et vous 3 parce que madame kratsa de
repartir dans les mythiques merci à vous
d'avoir été sur le plateau des chaînes
parlementaires pour ce grand débat animé
sur la place de l'europe dans la
campagne française on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à bruxelles
bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires